[Musique]
à
voici double jeu avec laurent baffie
françois rollin philippe corti leur
amour amanda lear evelyne leclercq
sophie darel et adeline hallyday voici
double jeu spécial filles
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue aux folies bergères
pour double jeu
spécial fou
[Musique]
couleurs
m
tu le sais
visionnez
les fauteuils et canapés ne sont pas
venus de chez le teinturier dans des
bains au
c'est une idée ou c'est une idée alors
on va faire un mini débat en forme
d'interview parallèlement on va
commencer debout bah y'a pas tellement
d'autres solutions mais c'est sympa
comme accueil
on va être obligé
alors on va commencer par toi amanda
pourquoi moi bah parce que ça tourne
dans le sens l'appui
comment imaginer tue l'amour quand tu
étais petite fille ben je regardais je
voyais lille les films et puis les
revues les trucs journaux donc
j'imaginais ça avec des choeurs des
princes charmants le coucher de soleil
laval en longue date j'avais une vision
très rottiers très stéréotypé très
romantique statut avancé vers la suite
pas un bruit la première fois qu'on m'a
bousculé c'était pas du tout comme ça
quand ce n'est
pas vraiment ça wellink comment imaginer
tue l'amour quand j'étais petit très
romantique également comme un mandat moi
c'est blanche neige c'est le prince
charmant qui viennent réveiller après
son temps de sommeil
sachez qu'une part non pas de toute
façon c'est l'époque du muet
est ce que tu as été dirigée par ta
première bousculade
ah non pas
bousculade non c'était pas une
bousculade ailleurs mais on n'en parlera
plus tard le ventilateur voilà je dois
faire le va comment imaginer tué l'amour
quand j'étais petite fille mais je crois
que je l'imaginais pas été très surpris
quand c'était arrivé non j'ai toujours
pensé que les hommes étaient des petits
cochons je le pense toujours
favori des mandats quand j'étais petit
quizz euros c'est bien tard sain parce
que c'était j'étais la belle bête mais
oui mais parce qu'on était un peu
efféminé parfois il y avait certaines
pauses
j'extrapole mais c'est extrapolant
evelyne
torero mais c'est lucky luke a
contrairement à huy pas parce qu'il tire
plus vite nous sommes exactement
le vha mois s'était mis ko
un mandat comment as-tu appris en quoi
consistaient faire l'amour
ben se jeter sur grande soeur c'est un
copain 7ème art ans et des jumeaux c'est
déjà beaucoup
c'est des copains mais je savais pas
qu'ils étaient jumeaux on connaît ses
15000 savais pas qu'il y avait un frère
jumeau revenons que je suis sorti avec
un puisse relier avec son copain j'ai
quand même quelques quelle santé et il y
en avait deux et bim comment as-tu
appris en quoi consistaient faire
l'amour j'ai appris sur le tas avant
on aurait vite fait le vert
celle inverse c'est lui qui a mis sur le
tas
au jour le jour mais où
s'interpréter toujours les réponses
d'une façon s'est bâti tu le connais tu
le rencontres aime aussi le oui tu
connais le personnage lova lova moi
j'étais dans un petit village alors
évidemment les petits course et les
grands dans les champs et puis on
regarde et on apprenait en regardant la
première fois tu as vu qu'ils en train
de pratiquer le curé
ça va passer non j'ai vu
ma soeur et son fiancé un mandat que
dirais tu es une gamine qui voudraient
savoir se débrouiller en amour quels
conseils lui donnerait dessus
faut apprendre au fur et à mesure je
prends découvre tout soi-même la peine
que quelqu'un donne des conseils dispo
faire s'il faut toucher ça c'est on
découvre tout comme ça moi je les
connais bien
pire est une gamine qui voudraient
apprendre à se débrouiller en amour ou
par exemple à ma fille puisque j'ai une
fille de 20 ans dort et à gruissan et à
qui je nous toutes les deux nous avons
souvent abordé ce sujet ensemble et je
lui ai toujours conseillé et dit m il
faut aimer il faut pas faire l'amour
avec quelqu'un qu'on aime pas donc et
mais d'abord et fait l'amour après ce
sera tellement plus beau ça va je
conseillerais de regarder canal +
concertation
pendant deux ans
qu'est ce qui te fait craquer chez eux
avec amanda
soient franches nobuta cup tout dépend
si bien dire moi ou c'est une tourner le
dos s'il vient vous
vient vers moi c'est les yeux sourire
chine toi le dos et dev center
cd fais pas ce que je veux dire que les
titres les arbitres les bonshommes monde
est très jolies fesses bergé qu'est ce
qui te fait craquer mais non ce qui me
fait craquer chez un homme moi c'est
l'humour d'abord j'aime bien les gens
qui me font rire et j'adore ça et puis
je pense que la vie est assez difficile
et triste pour avoir besoin de se
détendre et c'est vrai que bon le côté
physique est aussi intéressant puisque
la première approche que l'on a de
quelqu'un qui soit un homme ou une femme
c'est une physique évidemment donc on
accroche non pas les fait pas forcément
qu'est-ce que de l'autre côté qu'est ce
qui te fait craquer en premier chez un
mec seul regard ce regard dans le regard
on voit le sexe de l'homme regardez-moi
question comment tu vois c'est pas mal
souffert la saison réussie c'est le
problème qu'est ce qui les fait craquer
chez toi les mecs ils pas mandat la voix
souvent comme c'est au téléphone comme
qu'on compare nos
à léo tu m'entends c'est plutôt la voie
des toits qu'est ce qui les fait craquer
les matches mais contrairement à un
mandat je ne peux jouer ni sur des gens
ni sur mes cheveux donc je tape dans un
autre registre est l'un de mes meilleurs
amis qui me connaît depuis plus de 20
ans m'a dit bon et vine soyons réalistes
maintenant ne se retourne plus vraiment
sur toi dans la rue mais tu gagnes est
connu mais je les prie pour un
compliment que je me sens très bien et
c'est vrai je vous le dis enfin je gagne
à être connue croyez moi et toi qu'est
ce que tu crois la bouche à bouche ouais
ça se comprend
tu sais quand madame ans tu as eue dans
ta vie amanda aux milliers et milliers
d'hommes dans ta vie
censé être à peut-être que j'ai bien
zéro mi mandat face à la télévision tout
le monde s'écoute et j'ai mis à zéro non
moi je ne compte pas et j'ai un gros
problème c'est que je suis très fidèle
et en dehors de sa bombe dans une telle
voie là où il pas je n'ai pas une
expérience grosse dizaine est importante
dizaines si ça vous fait plaisir
certainement un
toit j'ai dit je ne la fausse
évidemment
et tu vois moi avec mon corps je suis
assez sage mais bien dans ma tête chez
des folies jeu les folies la nuit dans
les rêves un bon ouais je trouve que
c'est meilleur
combien de savoir combien la vie sont
prêts
abandon par nuit bon c'est comme la plus
qu'autre chose mais c'est moi que la
meilleure même mois
chanson
on va faire beaucoup de bien aux
téléspectateurs ce que je propose c'est
comme quand on est dans un spécial
blondin spécial filles c'est qu'on fasse
une minute de silence est ce que vous
êtes capable de faire une minute de
silence nous oui mais vous certainement
c'est parti
d'une minute tout un monde ouvrier des
colorants
s'il vous plaît sans lieux publics et 6
interdit de fumer c'est une invitée
quand même un steak sinon seraient
interdits cube est invitée ou pas
je crois que les professeurs voile a
demandé la parole dans non je ris je
voulais vous interromps parce que je
suis scandalisé mais vraiment
scandalisés par votre façon de faire
vous êtes comme les autres finalement
votre dit matt est en chute libre 1 vous
savez plus quoi faire pour remonter la
pente alors vous nous sortez trois
supers nanas canon avec les seins à
l'air voilà toujours la même bouée de
sauvetage le sexe toujours la même chose
n'est-ce pas alors évidemment que vous
êtes vous êtes comme les autres vous
êtes comme les sabatier comme les
foucault comme les deux chavannes vous
êtes en perte de vitesse mon propre
thierry vous savez plus quoi faire pour
gagner des points alors vous nous sortez
des duchesses et allez hop du sexe mais
ça porte un nom ce que vous faites mon
cher thierry ça s'appelle du racolage
tout simplement et bien moi je vais vous
dire thierry je condamne fermement ce
genre de procédé et je demande aux
téléspectateurs d'en faire autant de
sanctionner ce genre de pratique au non
pas aux attentes parce que je ne me fais
pas d'illusions les autres chaînes
utilisent les mêmes méthodes de racolage
mais tout simplement en éteignant leurs
postes de télévision éteignez vos postes
de télévision mes amis ne cautionnait
pas le racolage éteignez les maintenant
redécouvrez les choix d'un bon bouquin
comme celui-ci l'amour écorché de
bernard huvelin c'est paru chez grasset
c'est formidable les airs découvraient
les joies de la lecture éteignez vos
postes de télévision éteignez les voilà
thierry bon goût et reprendre vos
petites affaires plus personne ne
regarde c'est
parce qu'il a ce soir
[Musique]
nous attend à la fin de cette émission
et que je l'espère va tous passer avec
nous une sacrée soirée alors lova j'ai
essayé de taper sur ton minitel 36 15
lova moor je vais te dire ce que j'ai
trouvé d'abord il ya l'actualité de
l'eau va hein c'est quoi l'actualité de
l'eau va
là où je vais faire mon shopping là où
je vais boire le thé
qu'est ce que je raconte en dit des
choses banales il ya tout sur leur amour
sur la beauté sur la mise en forme sont
les produits que j'utilise tout sur leur
amour il ya jusqu'au bout avec le vin
moore stéphane club de lova moor qu'est
ce que les paroles des chansons de lova
moor devenez parolier pour leur amour
les petites annonces de lova moor alors
y'a un truc terrible lova moor en
espagne
c'est pas ça il ya le jeu de lova moor
et ce qu'on gagne quand on gagne au jeu
de lova moor on gagne une soirée
d'horaire avec toi alors c'est quoi ça
et puis qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette soirée de rêve avec notamment un
sur dix ans
l'aref pattes ça consiste en quoi et la
personne peut correspondre avec moi ah
c'est tout c'est tout la soirée de rêve
avec l'om en c1 à droite israël par la
voix sans déconner quoi
non ça veut dire qu'on blague à part
c'est très con passer une soirée avec
toi on joue sur les mots c'est pas ta
minitel
bleu c'est pas michael rose ah d'accord
je suis un peu déçu là un peu déçu que
ça qu'il pensait commencer vraiment une
soirée avec toi oui à bombay si tu veux
je peux te faire ce paisible ça peut
s'arranger oui tu es marié c'est pour ça
bien sûr vous peut être mariée et être
infidèle on a des images de ton mariage
là tu veux qu'on les regarde pourquoi
pas un fronton petit et les regarde on
débouche appel
à vous jurés n'ont bernard belin pas
comme certaines portes et d'autres
établissements la peau d'un d'entre eux
développer
il s'agit d'une authentique rodez et une
réforme qui vous coûtera pas trop cher
en vêtements un rien l'habille le savait
depuis longtemps je connais et moments
de tension dans l'hémicycle mais rien à
voir avec la tension qui électrise les
clients d'une résidence grâce à vous le
vélo
rend chez un copain vous et moi alain
bernardin vous effeuiller les superbes
créatures que l'on admire vous et moi je
retire tout aux contribuables lui autant
jusqu'à sa chemise
mitterrand bernard d'un même combat
alala va vous êtes unies pour le tir
mais vu les derniers sondages de
millions qui vous concerne vous ne serez
bientôt pour le meilleur à qui je gêne
là bas
qu'est ce qui est un record s'il vous
plaît c'est interdit de fumer ici c'est
un lieu public c'est un lieu public cet
interdit de fumer je m'excuse
pour être là
l insupportable les chefs de rayon
alors le vagin j'ai lu récemment dans la
presse que tu lisais marguerite duras
oui c'est vrai mais c'est un gars qui
n'ont pas du tout j'ai lu j'ai
découverte marguerite duras avec l'amant
jeu les débours en une nuit et cette
femme purifie part par la façon de
manier son verbe elle a une écriture
d'une pureté bas qui me remplit de
bonheur et je les adore alors tu te
donnera pas que je te fasse un projeté
express alors vous projetez express et
le questionnaire de proust version mac
do oui tu es prête alors quel est pour
toi le comble de la misère
s'est campé dans une rolls way pour
quelle faute à tu le plus d'indulgence
les crimes passionnels ton peintre
favori au noir ta qualité préféré c'est
ce que fait un bond à ça c'est très bien
ce qu'elle fait à mende à
ccc vrai toi t'es pas venu pour rien oui
ton principal défaut
la fini hantise ce que tu déteste par
dessus tout me lever très tôt le matin
le don de la nature que tu voudrais
avoir
sera maître chiron bien pouvoir faire
qu'est ce qu'un chirurgien tant aimé
sauver des vies ici que tu sauvent des
vies tu selva
comment aimerais tu mourir
enseigne en sept mois là maintenant joue
plus au nord l'état présente ton esprit
là c'est quoi il est à présent
je n'ai libye dinner le bond du non dit
pour ce faire une petite info ou intox
c'est une question de valérie père et de
paris corinne ses gammes aux grosses
têtes
alors là vous êtes toutes les trois dans
le cou aux usa il existe une chaîne
câblée pour chiens
abanda lire à mon avis c'est vrai sont
blâmables les amerloques c'est bon si tu
dis que c'est vrai toi aussi je pense
que c'est vrai je voulais exactement
dirais même chose que toi ils sont
capables de tout donc pourquoi pas une
chaîne privée info et huawei je sais
qu'on peut faire arrêter ces animaux oui
bon si je pense que c'est bien fou une
chaîne câblée pour les chiens et bien
bravo les applaudit toutes les trois
c'était de marquer
il remporter très vite un immense succès
aux états unis et en 150 chiens
participent tous les jours au show de
doc tv donc valérie père et de paris
gagnent 500 francs et corti tu nous
donnes le score bien sûr il ya des deux
shows yade et d'options évidemment le
score corps type
lova moor
et valides m amanda
bravo
alors maintenant après le proust express
auquel tu as très bien répondu on va
faire une interview coq à l'âne
messina tabou coq à l'âne c'est des
questions qu'ils fassent du coq à l'âne
quelle est l'insulté qui t'a fait le
plus mal dans ta vie
lorsqu'on m'a cru idiote stupide
c'est un constat sans appel
vientiane
là
[Applaudissements]
à genoux je mets ce qui demande pardon
la maîtresse je m'excuse je ne ferai
plus
as tu déjà pensé au suicide
oui quant
à disons que très souvent je pense que
je vais programmé ma mort c'est moi qui
l'a programmerait tu écris quoi quand on
me demande des autographes
c'est banal j'écris bisous le var bisous
le oui est ce que tu m'aimes moi oui je
t'aime beaucoup beaucoup oui jusqu'à
quel point
je te connais pas intimement nom était
partout j'aime ton intelligence et puis
je trouve que tu est hyper séduisant
parce que tu ressembles un prêtre
[Applaudissements]
sous la torture qui dénonceraient tu en
premier
un contre
tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
non ça ne marque pas c'est pas la peine
non comment se sont tous couchés ne pas
réussir
c'est géré année quand as tu pleurais
qui fait monter l'audimat on savait que
l'audimat
chez moncton a dit
jay leno
tu pleurais pour la dernière fois pour
la dernière fois
lorsque j'ai perdu un ami
ou aimerais-tu être enterré dans le
petit village je suis né quelle est la
dernière personne que tu ai eu envie de
tuer
des tué
ma fille
c'est vrai que c'est tentant c'est
tentant non j'adore est ce que tu
pourrais faire draguer ou de faire
draguer
j'aime bien me faire draguer
et donner l'impression d'ignorer
cette avance était assez pervers mais tu
préfères l'arrêt ou de faire larguer ont
largué évidemment à quoi reconnait tu
infailliblement la passion naissante
chez un mec on regarde
que fais-tu si tu as besoin de
téléphoner dans la rue
tu n'as pas de mener est à télécartes
évident que fais tu ici toujours mon
téléphone portatif est abondante a pas
besoin de télé car on n'a pas besoin de
regarder ces sujets là les autres quand
même prenons notre petit téléviseur et
regardons rester les cartes a résolu les
problèmes de monnaie pour les usagers de
sécurité face au vandalisme dans les
cabines mais cette carte a dévoilé son
talon d'achille on sait déjà qu'en
passant une télé carte sous des
ultraviolets les informations la mémoire
s'efface les unités disparaissent ce que
l'on ne savait pas c'est que cette carte
se recharger ou froid à moins 20 degrés
pendant une demi journée ce qui se passe
et que la mémoire des puces des
télécartes est organisé sous forme de
couches d'informations qui sont empilées
quand vous téléphonez que vous consommez
une unité la couche du dessus est
effacée alors il ya un phénomène qui
s'appelle la mp complétude qui dit qu'à
partir de moins 20 degrés ces couches
commencent à se régénérer au l'inventeur
d'un truc ultra sensibles comme cette
carte qui portent de l'argent donc y est
un qui sera forcément attaquer par des
fraudeurs et c'est bien sûr que
bien sûr que ça vient forcément l'esprit
en tout cas ça m'est venu à l'esprit
mais je pensais plutôt à des choses lors
les rayonnements alpha ou peut-être des
petites météorites des choses comme ça
quoi ne jetez plus vos cartes épuisé un
passage au congélateur lui redonnera un
peu de vie une astuce que france télécom
n'a pas voulu commenter mais ne rêvez
pas toutes les cartes à puce ne sont pas
aussi dociles les cartes bancaires elles
sont hyper protégé vraiment aucun risque
pourquoi parce que toutes les
informations confidentielles toutes les
informations contenues à l'intérieur de
la puce sont pour des raisons de
confidentialité évidentes protégé par un
système de véro informatique et ce
verrou informatiques fonctionnent aussi
entre autres en cas de choc thermique
équiper les télécartes d'intel verrou
serait un investissement trop lourd gars
d'ici deux ans on utilisera sa carte
bancaire pour téléphoner
[Musique]
au congélateur
je vous le demande alors toi pottoks pas
vrai pourquoi tu peux mettre tout ce que
tu vaux congélateur ça se rechargent
passe pas vrai avant tu pourras pas toi
toi moi je pense que c'est de l'intox
parce qu'au contraire une puce qui est
en fait une carte à puce qui est
déchargé il faut la chauffer il faut
l'affronter sur le bras sur laquelle
vous frottez salah réchauffe et elle se
recharge
et toi toi tu dis info alors c'est un
sujet qui nous a été envoyé par monsieur
xavier hovasse qui habitent aux mille
dans le xiii tu connais c'est pas loin
de sa fille à côté de reims en provence
bonjour alors il a déjà gagné deux mille
francs puisqu'on a tourné son sujet
maintenant pour savoir si je rajoute
mille francs de ma poche on écoute la
réponse
[Musique]
c'est vrai que j'ai cru tout ça c'est du
pipeau c'est métal de la pointe de la
botte
voilà alors ces
attaques ont fait une seconde non c'est
impossible de passer de toute façon
malaisie sur les cartes de téléphone je
crois qu enfin bon vieux fautes qu'on
apprend à faire la belle emma nationale
ils voulaient réchauffe et non pas les
refroidir tu comme les hommes c'est la
même chose pour iphone et mon chêne je
comprends pas bien d'abord à la reine et
toi bats tu t'es planté
si c'est pas c'est pas grave pour
monsieur valls qui gagne 1000 balles de
plus ça fait quand même trois mille
francs à monsieur hovasse corti le score
pour ce qui est de décharger on peut pas
tomber un mandat ni evelyne deux points
alors que l'amour reste à un point
asenjo
et j'accueille maintenant mandat
et
alors avant de continuer l'émission et
avant d'interviewer amanda lear je
voudrais vous dire de rester avec nous
pour la surprise de la fin de l'émission
et nous passons une sacrée soirée alors
dit moi un mandat riccione ou à tf1
benj ans filles
j'en fais pas bernière fois qu'on le
voit sur france 2 parce que après tout
sera une cervelle jacques ben oui c'est
curieux j'étais en italie j'ai une
émission la barre la radio et ils m'ont
téléphoné qu'ils avaient pensé à moi
pour présenter cette grande émission du
samedi soir et dont j'ai été surprise
parce que j'ai dit pourquoi moi c'est
finalement canton il faut croire que il
voulait reformer un couple un couple
célèbre c'est à dire christian morin
amanda lear on avait lancé la 5 savez
mon marché
on est gros et ça n'a marché que quand
on y était oui quand on s'est arrêté que
c'est vrai moi ça n'a plus marché donc
je retiens vente voilà et donc ils
veulent réformer ce couple enquête on
sent un coup plein d'humour d'ironie et
voilà alors j'ai été très surprise et
puis maintenant le le choc passé je dis
pourquoi pas oui bien sûr samedi soir
j'ai rien à faire un jean berthon plus
sans arrêt non plus alors dis-moi
comment tu fais un chaud et doux pour
berlusconi c'est ça non en ce moment je
travaille pour la rai banda et pour la
rage c'est un show quotidien tous les
matins la radio et là les gens de toute
l'italie téléphone et tous les matins on
parle de tout de détaxe des élections
américaines des impôts de la mafia de
tout ce que tu veux et les gens
m'appellent en direct et je trouve ça
tellement grisant excitant d'avoir
vraiment l'opinion publique du bois du
fin fond de la cale 1 du japon menacé
s'il m'appelle et là il n'y a pas de
filtrage temps de m'appeler me dire des
horreurs d'ailleurs tous les matins je
me dis chouette on va peut-être 1 et
puis non finalement ça se passe
tellement ils sont comment les italiens
en ce moment et c'est vrai cette cette
division entre jusqu'à 10 du nord il ya
le succès a vraiment élevé la fameuse
dick et ça c'est grave parce que c'est
impossible de diviser l'italie du nord
les jeux c'est comme si on faisait une
ligne qui s'arrête à lyon tu vois les
gens ici dix ans car on ne le savait pas
marché ça faisait et puis en plus non il
ya des vilaines choses qui se passent un
italien en ce moment il ya un renouveau
du racisme il ya des problèmes
économiques il ya
tous les tous les hommes politiques sont
sont arrêtés pour des histoires de
pots-de-vin des affaires sans arrêt ici
aussi mais les arêtes poste
alors un italie bon ça va mal et moi ce
qui me touche le plus c'est que la lire
italienne et beaucoup tomber alors quand
tu reviens un peu gagné des fronts quoi
bas ne sont pas terribles efron en plus
ans à bonbons fournisseurs pour s'en
sortir à moi j'ai vu des voyantes
récemment par elisabeth tessier mais
d'autres voyons
qu'ils m'ont dit que ça on n'était pas
sorti de la merde a bondi vers yann
robin nous attendons toute l'année qui
vient là il ya avant l'économie tout ça
il va falloir s'accrocher
avant une émission alors baissé bah oui
on bosse l'émission de toile je mets
beaucoup
a dit quand j'étais au lit oui ça des
cancers d'acier de piquer vide et puis
toi ça lui a pas réussi du tout mais oui
il avait piqué l'idée d'un je lui ai dit
1 il va pas payer pour ça ben non mais
pour se faire pardonner m'avait invité à
faire sa dernière émission et il voulait
justement faire un grand machin montré
un truc olic finance ça s'est passé
parce que le pauvre s'est arrêté il a
pas montré cette émission tu recevais
les gens là moi j'aurais aimé qu'il a
mon ventre et abc choix qui la prends
ton petit téléviseur prenez votre petit
téléviseur on va voir amanda recevant
les gens au liban là c'était dans un
bolide satin
mystérieux et sa mère
son ambiant tellement profond n
tout montre hausse à l'amiable
j
non
émoussés c'est vrai
le torontois l'état
oh
m
c'est bon
conte
oh
les hommes politiques les footballeurs
tout le monde il a accepté de venir dans
le lit donc en moi et puis il faut
qu'ils aient dans le lisent était
paralysée terreur ils se disent qu'est
ce que je fous là qu'est ce que je fous
là alors c'est très curieux yves n'est
pas ce qu'il y avait une vieille libido
tu vois l'idée d'aller au lit avec
amanda lear puis après un sévère blanche
qu'est ce qui se passe encore mais le
public en soit il est confiant le
soutien du fumer c'est un lieu public
rue mais c'est un lieu public depuis le
début vous en plus c'est lui je vais
dire dans le genre prise de telles
bombes implantées gentili de khost
paul
bon enfin on va passer à l'interview
première fois est ce que tu es prête
amanda première fois première fois
premier souvenir
marchand mais pas de premier souvenir
c'est pas deux premiers de ce nom c'est
vrai premier souvient-il en a un tout
petit budget
le biberon chypre le biberon quand même
ou le biberon
pour une seule premier choc un premier
choc quand on m'a
on y arrivera j'aime bien longue wi fi
non un sacha une purge rire angers ce
que j'avais des premières fois où tu
étais retrouver toute nue avec un garçon
et par l'armée
non non ben csba c'est moche quand elles
apprécient
parce que j'avais beaucoup idéalisé tout
ça je le voyais un peu comme lui la wii
tout lisse doom harmonieux et ses jantes
en oman 1 et puis on se retrouve avec un
mec poilus
première expérience homosexuelle
hamon alors très mauvaise qualité ah bon
moi je suis une très mauvaise lesbienne
c'est même pas la peine que j'insiste
ne rien faire je laisse faire danser ses
premières expériences à plusieurs là
c'est pareil parce que c'est pas mon
truc que j'aime bien je suis un peu
égoïste au lit alors j'aime bien qu'on
s'occupe de moi tout seul alors je vais
vous partagez avec des copines et puis
attendre son tour et tout çà çà çà
premier mariage oui ton premier mariage
trois jours ah oui
non ça c'est la ruée des cinq ans à
l'armée lors ces trois jours mais ces
trois heures dans trois autres jours en
fait mon premier mariage c'était c'était
un coup de tête comme ça il m'a lu bing
folie je me voyais madame et puis après
le décès du maire je suis madame quelle
horreur nouba premier geste le matin
entre le vote les couilles
je serai que le premier geste en me
réveillant je me lève je vais dans la
salle de bain je me regarde dans la
glace
et
je me dis oui à la durée je me dis qu
est ce que je suis belle qu'est-ce que
je suis bien que ce que je suis bien
même si c'est pas vrai même si je trouve
que j'ai l'oeil bouffier tout qu'est-ce
que je suis bien c'est devenu une
habitude c'est très important ça fait
partie je te l'expliquerai du de ma
méthode de pensée positive quelle serait
ta dernière volonté si tu devais mourir
là maintenant tout de suite suite à main
là maintenant qu'elle sauvé ta dernière
vous lis pas de nourrir ma chatte parce
que
tiens
je vais très très dur
bon alors écoutez ça vous apprendra je
me faire une petite info intox surprise
c'est une question de ludovic
barbarossa barbarossa italien dans le
balo ça alors
les cas sévères alors vous êtes
concentré l'aube à evelyne amende à
un club anti dorothée
à temps a été créé à la rentrée par une
association de parents d'élèves ont
convenu que des aces de l'info est de
l'intox lova
intox intox
tu crois pas toi pourquoi elle est
charmante petite dorothée pourquoi le
sang est d'accord evelyne
je suis très ennuyé parce que dorothée
sur tf1 c'est la même famille mais la
télévision est une grande famille mais
j'ai entendu parler d'une information de
ce genre et je crains fort soit
d'information et je le déplore
d'ailleurs j'ai un temps fou pour tous
les goûts et le tulle pauvres gens voter
quelqu'un de très bien
elle a bien sûr alami un seau à
champagne sur la tête de buffy l'année
dernière donc c'est quelqu'un de pas
bien on va là et bonne copine non moi je
crois que c'est de l'info ouais j'aime
bien dorothée mais je peux comprendre
qu'elle peut irriter ses quatre
personnes des parents n'ont peut-être
pas les en étant donc je crois que c'est
un faux bond laurent oui c'est de l'info
ou de l'intox et en avait moi je pense
que c'est le wat de l'info
je sais pas
vous êtes tous plantés c'était de
l'intox
sauf l'eau va
alors ludovic barbarossa 25 150 on dort
watchmouse m enfin lui gagne 500 balles
et corti tu nous donnes le score j'ai
chaud derrière mais bon je peux dire que
amanda reste à deux points et vignes de
poing et gaz lâche lova moor égalise à
deux points bravoure
après l'interview première fois tu
comprendras qu'on fasse l'interview
dernier coup ça nous fait un an que
ça ne donnera pas tant dernier coup de
tête
[Musique]
oui c'est une maison ah bon ça reste
cher oui tu as vendu l'ancien et a pris
des ménages est trop de princesse alors
c'est bien c'était avant de connaître
bouygues parce que maintenant y aura
offert une coupe au tarif oui alors ça
tu évites
quoi oui qu'ils auraient plutôt faire
une petit
7e les grandes maisons bien les coups de
bluff
oh ça tout le temps quand on a signé le
contrat pour tf1 j'ai dû me bluffer
ouais tu leur as dit que je proposais
déjà et de gros besoins
dernier coup de boule c'est pas un coup
de blues boom
alors moi je la grèce verbalement lors
la fraterie parce que c'est pire que
tout se passe alors je dit des
méchancetés me décourage arrivant à des
horreurs ah bon tu vois ça j'ai une
langue
certes c'est vrai je peux il vaudrait
mieux que je frappe les gens pensent je
leur dis des choses et pouf terrible
après je regrette bien les coups de
coeur en or dernier coup de coeur ça
tout le temps moi j'ai des coups de
coeur c'est vrai que pour des tas de
choses pour mon des enfants pour des
objets pour des personnes pour tout le
temps je le regrette pour ça que j'ai
pas de pognon parce que j'ai tout par
des coups de coeur je marche à
l'instinct au coup de coeur parler des
coups de coeur pour la misère humaine
pour lui oui absolument les bosniaques
les choses comme ça peut-être les
bosniaques me touchent moins que ce que
j'ai tout près
dans dans un milieu d'amis tu vois là je
m'occupe du sida en angleterre bon en
fait je peux pas du sitar mais je sais
que en angleterre j'ai il ya plusieurs
associations ils sont mieux organisées
qu'en france une association dont j'ai
participé aux raids à mes rôles qui
s'occupe d'organiser des soirées de
bienfaisance à pour le sida j'en fais
partie bon jeu le jeu le crie pas sur
tous les toits je le fais en angleterre
je vais pas en france mais donc ça c'est
l'échelle drame de la belle carrie ce
n'était pas du tout touché par exemple
si bien sûr mais c'est le tueur en série
je vais te montrer ces espaces en
d'hakkari près aux petits téléviseurs
souple balkarie
presque un an après la naissance de la
communauté des états indépendants la coi
des conflits ethniques ne cessent
d'éclater un peu partout sur le
territoire de l'ex urss le sud de la
russie véritable mosaïque de peuples
tous différents vole en éclats et plus
particulièrement dans le caucase et le
moyen-orient soviétique d'ailleurs on y
retrouve les mêmes affrontements que
dans le moyen-orient proprement dit s'il
ya des toute une série de situations qui
rappelle le liban avec des milices qui
peuvent se faire la guerre aussi
longtemps qu au liban c'est à dire
quinze ans et puis c'est le tempérament
du midi c'est le soleil c'est les
montagnes un les montagnards on disait
au long poignard des sports doit on
appeler comme ça chez les russes y ont
d'ailleurs fondé une une fédération des
peuples montagnards du caucase et c'est
parce que les autorités russes ont
arrêté moussa chagny bof le chef de
cette fédération des peuples montagnards
que la balle car il vient de se soulever
cette toute petite république de sept
cent mille habitants est prise dans la
tourmente nationaliste les balles car
rêve d'indépendance
[Musique]
pour la communauté russe à paris la
situation actuelle est préoccupante car
elle est tout à fait semblable à celle
qui a déclenché la guerre serbo-croate
dans l'ex yougoslavie
c'est une [ __ ] c'est tout petit peu
dit
il via lui déplaire
ce faux pas duré longtemps s'il ya des
problèmes chez sony s'était fait l'écho
stigmates des régimes communistes
malheureusement la révolte en belle
karine et que l'une des 125 crise
ethnique recensés dans l'ex urss
c'est si beau riche et le sinaï n'avait
pas joué pour deux cochons gorbatchev en
ans et prend la vieux 1
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît c'est un lieu public
aussi
c'est un lieu public on ne fume pas
maintenant je suis pas à l'antenne à thé
gentil ça fait rien ne fume pas c'est un
lieu public messieurs enfin c'est mon
émission je fais ce que je veux quand
même je veux pas le savoir c'est un lieu
public je vois ici s'il vous plaît vous
êtes et nude cigarettes merci
à lui
dacoury la soirée je te dis pas tiens
bon on va reprendre sur des aplombs vous
y êtes
il avale caries
alors à toi lola atox je crois pas du
tout si ça fait un ton un peu de temps
je dirais un toc si je vais pas bien ça
balkarie non ça tu crois pas ça fait un
peu baby baby g 10 1 bd
non moi j'ai cru reconnaître didier
gustin brusquement dans le film à la fin
et ça fait un peu tout ça oui dont je
suis sûr c'est pas vrai y'a pas de
balkarie je le saurais si rennes bat
nice
s'est insurgé qui nous a été envoyé par
jean-luc miremont 75006 paris qui gagne
2000 francs puisqu'on a tourné son sujet
maintenant pour savoir si la plante et
amanda c'est quand même bien le 1 quel
veinard et oui et donc s'ils gagnent
1000 francs de plus que je mettrais de
ma poche on regarde la réponse c'est de
l'info tout à fait ben je suis
journaliste et on essaye de partir trop
de bêtises mais même si c'était faux
voici donc si je m'étais trompé voici la
classe universel fait par le monde où
nous avons là la balle car il en fait
une partie de la république autonome des
cas bardin et des balles car capital
naltchik avec ses frontières non c'est
clair comme le rose et voilà
je suis régulièrement l'émission donc je
crois que c'est un vrai ce trail vous
avez tous les trois toutes les trois est
trop lente et
on est très très content jean luc myre
mamba lui va empocher trois mille balles
1 ce qui n'est pas rien et corti tu va
nous donner le score écoute moi avec
tout sex symbol je sais même plus où
j'en suis je sais même plus si c'est des
nems faut de l'intox mais je peux vous
donner le score ne l'est qu'à égalité
parfaite 2 partout
j'accueille maintenant un vulgaire à mes
côtés
[Musique]
alors je crois que tu connais laurent
baffie vous êtes ensemble dans l'est
dans les grosses têtes donc quand vous
dites on est ensemble ces façons de
parler des sciences nous nous sommes
croisés quelquefois sur le plateau de
rtl avec ce plaisir c'était parfois un
petit peu difficile mais bon moi parce
que tu as on y monte pas toujours très
vous appelez ça d'humour ou
non mais c'est un garçon en dehors de
l'émission il est tout à fait charmant
voilà beaucoup d'humour c'est triste
surtout je crois qu'il en faut
et là je prends des risques encore ce
soir mais c'est avec plaisir c'est toi
qui regarde souvent les missions du
caunes elsa fichot bien sûr cette
période moi j'aime tout ce qui est
humide dans la vie j'aime bien rire je
pense que c'est l'essence même de
l'existence à quelques niveaux que ce
soit que ce soit premier deuxième
troisième degré bon c'est vrai que
laurent animaux très particulier parfois
un peu saignant sanglant mais c'est pas
inintéressant et je crois que vous avez
quelque chose à nous proposer bas
exactement exactement lors d'un fils
dati chaud
[Musique]
alors qu' on voit de la police est assez
rare ouais il en faut un petit peu quand
même oui il y en a on n'est pas riche et
la lune secondaire coses on connaît pas
une seconde deuxièmement je te choque
dans le quartier toit targa ta casquette
en fait non ça va un peu mieux ce
qu'est l'an passé sous la
pas qu'elles ont pas fait perdre ine
alors la rue regarde les nerfs et une
seconde chez avec monsieur là je te
cause seconde tuent à coups de boutoir
de mon art enseignements qu'ils me
donnent connard celle flic pg il tech
est pas dans le quartier doit
on est plus en sécurité 1 1
tu sais ce n'est fait mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
vols la porte de clignancourt une
seconde chez avec madame ai dit qu'on te
demande un renseignement pardon
tu peux me répondre
on va parler qu'on a enseigné encore est
ce que vous les voulez que j'appelle des
collègues et qu'on vous en bas qui font
ça dans la gueule pour coup des
boulettes si tu as des couilles et une
mère fils et 20 je ne crois pas dans le
quartier que ça a l'airé conseil c'est
ça
non pas du tout
pardon il est bien beau mais dis donc
justement une arythmie rythme annuel
alors tu vas me répondent oui attendez
je suis avec monsieur tueront pas
les moyens maintenant
que je te croise quoi en quart et les
aide pas mal hein mais je te croise pas
loupé connexes non non je l'aimais le
sapin pro de nettoyage
et 177
non je pensais que je veux pas lui
mettre il a été sympa quand même vous
réponds que je te demande un truc j'en
ai plein des flics deux ans que je
cherche dans le quartier toi t'as
interactions qui était miche ne crois
pas ça des impôts qu'on paye
toi et tes mois
ouais mais
vous voulez qu'on appelle la police on
veut pas faire plus et moi la police
monsieur thual une première je pense
qu'ils intègrent une espèce de connard
que je t'achète dans le quartier tu vas
voir ailleurs et maintenant un de merde
au
web la place clichy justement un connard
de pose d'une pièce que
je te pose à bas monsieur lessard viable
répondre monsieur connard
espace comprend pas ouais c'est quand
l'autre vallonnements il est emmené au
club pourquoi tu t'écrases comme ça
maintenant on va bourrer la gueule ça le
calme et un mort tu as vu en plus non
seulement ça nous des foules mais ça va
des foules et les gens qui rêvent de
taper sur les flics
fait le sait pas inaccessible après les
rouleaux te le
[Applaudissements]
professeur will tear et je voudrais
ajouter une chose parce que j'ai bien vu
que j'ai créé un petit malaise tout à
l'heure je voudrais vous dire vous savez
il n'ya pas que le sexe et les nanas
comme solution pour attirer les
téléspectateurs puisque c'est ça le but
il ya des tas d'autres choses en exemple
entre mille par exemple pourquoi ne pas
faire une émission sur les régions de
france à la salle intéresse les gens
vous savez moi je circule à longueur
d'année en province et les gens ils me
le disent ils me disent on s'en fout de
savoir avec qui couchent evelyne
leclercq guise nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est qu'on parle de notre
région la picardie le morvan le limousin
ça c'est les vrais sujets qui
intéressent les français comprenait les
français sont très attachés à leur
région bien plus qu'au sein de lova moor
alors ricaner maintenant tirer ricaner
mais réfléchissez là-dessus dormait là
dessus on en reparlera vous verrez que
les régions c'est pas si bête
réfléchissez à ça bien écoute je crois
professeurs on va l'applaudir
j'avais jamais
alors avant d'interviewer evelyne
leclercq je voudrais vous dire chers
téléspectateurs de rester avec nous pour
la surprise de la fin de l'émission je
vous promets que vous allez passer une
sacrée soirée
alors eveline tu sors tu sors un disque
oui avec que débat de chansons d'amour
entre hutus et que des belles chansons
d'amour ya quoi dessus il ya c'est une
espèce de medley avec une vingtaine de
chansons des classiques quoi là on
époque les roses blanches tous voilà
l'avion c'est si bon
j'ai commis tout ça mais revu et corrigé
et arrangé par charlie charlie est la
même il faut le dire
c'est un gars qui nous demanderons de
venir pour l'émission de noël rock'n
roll ce que le pen est à la démocratie
mais vous ne savez peut-être pas c'est
que charlie avait quand même accompagné
entre autres joséphine baker et johnny
hallyday à l'hôpital
où ça fait mal aux fidèles du beau monde
va mieux dieu merci tu peux pas enchanté
humain c'est si bon de partir n'importe
où bras dessus bras dessous en chantant
des chansons
c'est si bon de te veux dans les yeux je
sais plus par un sourire merveilleux
mais qui en disent long
en voyant votre mine ravie jeudi un
petit bout
oui
un manga qui va enchanter lui manon la
même balle à main louis accès si bon je
sais dire des mots tout des beauty rien
du tout mais qui en disent long le battu
peut joindre à
gillot va maintenant attention les
filles c'est si beau
temps belle chanson sur les
animaux de saison
mais rien n'y
fait
me ravit c'est bon les passants
nous envie
je tenais selon m
[Applaudissements]
oui
alors il ya une pièce qui s'appelle coup
de foudre oui de francis joffo avec kia
avec patrick préjean maurice risch et
une ma meilleure amie sophie darel s'est
améliorée mais oui on se connaît depuis
qu'on est tout petit un bon ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'elle est resté quand
même petit moi j'ai grandi depuis sophie
bien sophie darel
tu veux l'emporter en partant en étant
celui là il est pour un mandat je
pensais alors moyens comme d'habitude
ashiq soit la bête j'ai toujours des
restes mois
tu verras tu gagnes est connue je lui ai
dit au début de l'émission
alors cette pièce là qu'est ce que parce
que tu es sa meilleure amie peut-être
mais dans la pièce est normal c'est vrai
que je suis pas très sympa on fait quand
même aussi je suis quand même gentil
c'est à dire que dans la pièce c'est
exactement l'inversé dans la vie c'est
alors que moi je suis une chienne et
elle c'est une fille très bien oui merci
c'est juste l'un verse dans la vie tout
passe pas du tout comme ça alors qu'en
réalité dans la vie c'est une chienne et
moi je suis une fille très bien
qu'on est très très élevé avec un
problème vous entendez bien ça va on est
on est on sait on s'entend vraiment très
bien c'est vrai que dans la pièce je
suis je suis la petite amie de son mari
1 mais elle le prend assez bien
finalement ça se passe pas mal enfin je
crois que c'est une pièce qui pour
l'instant fonctionne très bien ça fait
deux jours que
nous la jouer et il ya du monde partout
partout partout on refuse du monde non
si janot n'est pas l'air étonné côté non
sais pas si on va cuisiner dis moi oui
moi ce que j'aime c'est quantité des
imitations tu peux pas m'en faire une
deux là juste pour moi tu aimes vraiment
toi ouais
je sais pas qu'est ce que tu veux que je
te fasse je parle d'imitation oui
bafé nous mira et on va voir le zizi
gelé trop patent du temps du temps du
jeu veut croquer le fruit défendu sans
défendu j'ai parcouru la planète même
pas une petite conquête et pourtant j'ai
très envie de voir et sourit arrêtez moi
si
une autre mais si tu veux que je te
fasse zimbardo oui je suis bien parce
qu'elle est c'est ma copine
véronique sanson si tu veux
si un temps attends tu perds mais la
providence si je me fais belle c'est
pour lui dit il
c'est un employé de la télé
il faut mais pas très gentil
et il s'appelle le bon tiers
des chalands en faire beaucoup alors a
vu
de la fumée vous fumez vous ils passent
la soirée nous expliquer que c'est un
lieu public et après il fait mieux
oui mais en fait j'ai bien réfléchi ici
c'est un lieu privé
ça un lieu privé ah bon
qui réfléchit alors comment on se
connaît pas bien on va faire une
interview check up et quand on aura fini
l'interview tchèque at on se connaîtra
très bientôt quel bonheur ton nom
est vite passé ton prénom leclerc
leclerc c'est en vrai nom est le c est
le rcq parce que c'est qc belge ah bon
d'accord je croyais pas du tout que
c'était pour ça tu as des surnoms
d'abord
non ma fille m'appelle nanane
bon c'est tout angeli t'appelles comment
lui il m'appelle pas parce que j'ai pas
de jules
t.gil t'appelles comment alors moi il
m'appelle pas
de temps en temps mais vous des dates de
naissance il ya beaucoup je sais je sais
je sais je n'ai jamais caché avec votre
de la secousse et marie
ça va tu es et la tienne nous a donné
cette visite que de 58 non j'ai eu 41
ans je sais que je les fais largement la
télé ça esquinte pas mal mais bon non
mais j'ai pas de problème à ce niveau là
je me sens bien je ne sais pas si vous
me sentais bien
die
en largeur
alors ma deuxième question
je sais pas 163
je parlais en cm ton point alors ça ça
va rien à toto est variable
je suis fâchée avec ma valence depuis un
mois oui ça c'est un sujet tabou tour de
poitrine ça c'est pas tabou du tout
parce que mes consoeurs ce soir les
montres et les leurres générale et alors
des bleus allez on va faire un petit
tour de poils moi j'ai un peu camouflée
alors bon laurence et dans les 90 jours
10 82 souffle à monsieur connaissait en
en 90 ans quel bonheur
dans les baies je pense combien le bâton
de potelets à 90 ça tient dans la main
d'un honnête homme s'est concocté fait
de la prison plus 90 ça tient dans la
main dans
un monde à moi ça dépend
tout dépend du soutien gorge ouais ya
des jours où 100 et des jours avec et
ans et avec seulement 5 cm avec le
soutien gorge moi je parle là ce soir
c'est à leur guise et 92
des bars des soutiens gorge et puis à
d'autrefois ou au contraire je les
montre absolument pas la lie à rien
c'est l'autoroute c'est tout droit et
le n'est tombé à ferfay l'origine en ce
temps était d'origine les dangers au
regret de vous le dire tout et
d'original dans aussi oui le cheveu gras
ou ce qu on sait qu abominable mahb les
téléspectateurs ont pu le constater
depuis longtemps mais ils m'ont pardonné
aussi longtemps les yeux alors tu as tes
yeux formidable fines de claire numéro
de c
mieux l'enterrer stigma n'ont rien cédé
10 disent oui plus que ça même j'ai une
vision plus importante que la moyenne ah
bon tu vois quoi la exemple on voit
quand je vois de la nuit
non mais je vois que les gens nique ta
doc nyctalope oui mais pas prêt ce bus à
un groupe cdc une partie de tiger
mais en fait je n'ai rien de particulier
je me demande même ce que je fais dans
ce métier je n'ai absolument je suis
quelqu'un de très banal en fait t'as pas
de grain de beauté des rues de prague la
cicatrice de tatouage banon non mais
c'est bien mais thébaux cher c'est
nickel un peu cher mais
je crois qu'après cette édition qui n'a
rien mais j'espère le ch donc j'attends
gauche à droite hier droitière bêtement
une enfance pauvre ou riche je dirais
moyenne ces dits pauvres y aura laissé
dirige ce sera pas vrai mais française
georges et là tu as une petite fille de
français moyens avec un papa et une
maman que j'adore et que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs très fort oui tiens je peux
c'est comme à tournez manège exactement
c'est pareil finalement tous et la
télévision tu autodidactes ou diplômé en
démo de simples ajustements
il est super
autodidacte il est pas grossier livre il
ya vraiment infiniment de talent et ça
attire des gens qui y est non non
autodidacte mais un peu diplômés quand
même si j'ai eu mon bac à 16 ans vous
quand
même j'ai mon brevet de pilote d'avion
que j'ai eu à l'âge de 19 ans
les licences de [ __ ] qu'elle est à
non ce qui me tient à coeur leur est bon
c'est bon la télévision c'est venu j'ai
appris sur le tas comme j'ai dit au
début de l'émission c'est beaucoup de
travail est-ce que prenant un mode
simple oui lequel son emploi maison
ça c'est cochon ça ah bon d'accord donc
tu sais ce que ça veut dire j'en ai
vaguement entendu parler qu'arthur lui
savait pas si tu veux ah oui non je suis
maison
j'ai une question que je laisse pas de
poser il ya clic y'a que les presses
réponses qui sont indiscrètes bon match
à la pause alors oui vas-y fréquences
hebdomadaires des rapports sexuels là ça
t'étonne rien hebdomadaire tu veux dire
quotidien combien de fois par sa
question était malheureuse ont bien
donné à dire c'est une semaine
on reprend tout à zéro
justement alors il faut que je fasse une
multiplication par 7 parce qu'être de
modérer galles 7 jours défaut que je
multiplie par sept oui alors 3 x 7 21 21
on applaudit et d'une ligne
maintenant peut-être parce que je
présentais à vous de savoir la presse de
l'info est de l'intox
qui est
jaloux on va faire une petite interro
surprise une question de henri lourdou 0
4 200 sisteron cette pâte les filles
c'est quoi le score corte mais quelle
égalité
à dix entre le village d'astérix at il
réellement existé
le bas
tu penses que beaucoup
un mandat non c'est une invention de
goscinny d'air
moi je veux dire oui parce que dans
toutes les questions que l'on pose dans
cette émission
neuf fois sur dix c'est un faux alors
qu'on ne s'y attend pas du tout donc je
veux dire un fou mais j'ai peur que tu
es perdu c'est de l'intox c'est pendant
ces vacances d'adolescents bretagne que
goscinny
s'est inspiré de faits historiques réels
pour inventer le personnage d'astérix et
le village d'astérix henry lourgouilloux
de sisteron gagne donc 500 francs on
l'applaudît
à la fin vision et violet clair toutes
parts à mandelieu que les boys love boat
trip pointe ouais
alors tout à répondre par oui ou par non
d'accord non
alors si tu le trompe et je lui dirai
non
est-ce que tu qui traite ou pour le
grand amour
oui
est-ce que tu tu aimes pas du tout est
ce que tu fais l'amour avec charly oleg
tantine d'ilham la mine avec charly oleg
pour un million de nouveaux francs alors
un million de nos francs d'avoirs fauche
calcul en brique par brique effectifs a
indiqué robin non il ya une condition
sinequanone qui fait que je ne ferais
jamais l'amour avec charlie malgré toute
l'affection que lui portent ses qu'il
est marié que je connais bien sa femme
que je l'apprécié infiniment et pour moi
il est hors de question de
d'avoir une relation quelconque avec un
homme qui est déjà avec quelqu'un
d'autre
les a mariés quand même que c'est que
cette histoire ah non j'aime pas du tout
je donne beaucoup mais je demande
beaucoup aussi parce que je suis assez
clair très clair oui merci jeu que le
message passe bien noté
ça j'en rêve lune je te veux dire ah
ouais est ce que tu crois qu'on vienne -
vite quand on habite en hauteur
alors je n'ai jamais réfléchi à cette
question
je n'étais pas au courant de sujets je
crois que ça n'a rien à voir bon ben
regarde 30 ans petit téléviseur
le temps ces novices et une société
c'est c'est une culture c'est beaucoup
de choses à la fois
à quand sa passe des vacances tandis que
les cours aient la passe de trois
c'est peut-être désillusion c'est les
questions existentielles contrôle sur la
vie
c'est très accéléré par rapport à
d'autres endroits comme la compagnie
chacun vit différemment la succession
des jours des nuits et des saisons
l'idée du temps qui s'écoule est une
notion toute relative
cette impression est intellectuel moral
ou psychologique mais plus surprenant
encore elle est prouvée scientifiquement
le temps passe plus ou moins vite selon
l'endroit où l'on se trouve albert
einstein relayée par des astrophysiciens
célèbre à expliquer ce phénomène
dans le cadre de la relativité générale
le temps n'est pas une donnée absolue le
temps l'écoulement du temps plus tôt
est affecté par la présence des masses
autour du point où vous vous trouvez
imaginons par exemple que des hommes à
vivre partent vivre sur jupiter donc une
planète beaucoup plus importante que la
nôtre eh bien ils vivraient beaucoup
plus longtemps que nous pourquoi parce
que le temps à la surface de cet objet
très massif et bien ralenti ralenti
évidemment par rapport à nous selon la
même théorie une horloge placé au sommet
du mont-blanc tournera plus vite qu'une
horloge identique posée au niveau de la
mer la différence calculé en
milliardièmes de seconde peut être
mesurée par des horloges atomiques
cette théorie nous concerne tous une
jumelle qui habite au 30e étage d'un
gratte-ciel vieillira plus vite que sa
soeur installée au rez-de-chaussée un
tel raisonnement devrait garantir au
gardien d'immeuble une longévité à toute
épreuve
plus on vieillit vite
lova
intox
amanda c'est de l'info un fou alors
c'était un sujet qui nous a été envoyé
par robert bedel de lyon qui gagne déjà
2000 francs puisqu'on a tourné son sujet
maintenant pour savoir si je vais
rajouter mille francs de ma poche on
écoute qu'est ce qui se passe un mandat
et à bafé qui envoie des signes
aux mégots de la réponse la réponse est
oui
depuis einstein et sa théorie de la
relativité on sait que le temps est
élastique c'est à dire en fait qu il ne
s'écoule pas de la même façon pour tout
le monde ces effets sont tout à fait
mesurable bien que extrêmement minime à
l'échelle d'une vie humaine par exemple
il ne se
contenterait quand milliardième de
milliardième de seconde donc les
téléspectateurs qui vivent dans les
étages supérieurs de leurs immeubles ne
se précipite pas au rez de chaussée dans
l'espoir de vivre plus longtemps alors
c'était violent
j'ai mal compris la question excusez moi
bon et toi tu m'avais dit quoi c'est 10
de l'info donc c'est bien et toi tu
m'avais dit quoi info info corti le
score
j'ai remonté la gagner et de justesse
devenue ce qu'elle a gagné
amanda lear a gagné ce soir oui
amanda balaton cette amende à
omerville
au
congo
mesdames messieurs
maintenant voici la surprise tant
attendu qu'on fasse entrer la surprise
et terminent ensemble cette sacrée soir
ces actions
il va bien
m
quelle est la plus grosse connerie que
fais tu dans ta vie oh
je sais pas
je veux qu'il y ait des gens n'étaient
pas mal ma plus grosse
j'en sais rien quand j'étais mariée est
ce que tu penses que tu a tout fait pour
garder ton mari ouais
ouais
[Rires]
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que tu ne
referait pas qu'est-ce que je referai
pas depuis le début de ma vie
je crois que veut je
serai allé voir le en fait le premier
garçon dont j'étais vraiment amoureuse
et que je serais allé lui montrer mon
amour sans orgueil son me drapé dans un
orgueil et lapointe et je serais allé
lui dire que je l'aimais vraiment et je
n'aurais pas laissé partir voilà
pourquoi tu l'as pas fait ça parce qu'il
est mort maintenant que j'ai pas eu le
temps et j'ai été congelé pas face à à
tanger attendu et puis bon il ya eu sein
je crois que c'était lui et l'homme de
ta vie
non je pense je pense pas sinon ils
seraient pas - ou alors je serais morte
aussi ou non j'ai enfin en tous les cas
j'espère pas parce que c'est dans ce cas
là ma vie est foutue
et puis si je pensais vraiment que ça
mais tu es l'homme de ma vie je pense
pas je m'en serais mariée couple
tu amoureuse en ce moment
donc autant de voix en photo dans les
journaux avec un acteur américain très
charitable pourquoi parce que parce que
parce qu'on a trop volés ma vie privée
en la jetant en pâture au public alors
que j'étais pas d'accord je suis
d'accord de de donner un certain un
certain nombre de choses qui
m'appartiennent mais quand on vient de
les voler je suis pas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas envie de
répondre à cette question cette histoire
là j'ai envie de la préserver et j'ai
pas envie qu'on vient de me l'a gâché
avec des photos des cdd des photos de
paparazzi des choses comme ça je crois
qu'il va être marié
j'espère à 20 ans ça dommage de me dire
voilà ma fille c'est terminé pour toi tu
as plus tard marié oui j'espère que je
me remarier
ils voient comment nos 20 ans non
maintenant je me vois sereine avec toute
ma famille autour de moi dans une dans
une maison dans un dans un endroit où je
me sens bien avec avec des rires vous
partout tu as une baguette magique tu
ferais quoi comme métier j'avais une
baguette magique
chanteuse de hard rock ah bon
[Musique]
oh
ici
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu